- This is what the invisibility cloak
in Harry Potter was made out of.
(laughing)
(soft, happy music)
- Vanty black?
- Vantablack.
Vanta.
- Vanta.
- I know it's black.
Like, that's about it really.
- It's supposed to be the
world's blackest material.
And I'm like, what does that mean?
I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Blackest thing I've
ever seen are these socks,
that I'm wearing today.
- I'm imagining like
flubber, and it moves,
and it comes and like bites you.
- Oh my gosh.
I'm like nervous.
- I'm expecting when I turn this around,
something will be black.
- Three,
- [Both] Two, one.
Woah.
- I thought, I almost thought
I could see through it.
- I'm not able to see the creases of the,
foil essentially, so, it is pretty black.
- Wow, okay.
- It looks like it's
just like a rip in space.
- Like this is exists, and this exists,
and the middle black bit does not exist.
- So here you can like, totally see it.
And then here it's just like.
- Yeah, I can't see any
texture in it at all.
- So can you make outfits out of this?
- That's incredible!
What a great Halloween outfit.
- In comparison,
my socks now are very,
very, very dark blue.
- So, this is the
blackest commercial paint
that you can buy.
This is flocking,
it's used to line telescopes
to stop stray light.
This is the Ventablack.
- Okay, we put it over this one,
there's a big reflection.
Put it over that one,
- You can definitely see the reflection.
- [Man in flannel shirt] You
put it over this one and like.
- It's an actual black hole!
- And this is the blackest
paint that you can buy.
It's pretty much gray.
It's almost white.
- I wanna compare really
quick to my yuma pants,
which I have with me.
It's crazy how reflective they are.
Like these are supposed to be black, what?
- You might have to take it back.
'Cause if you imagine like
your ex girlfriend or
your ex boyfriend's heart
it's just as black as that.
- So, Ventablack is I guess is
hydrophobic.
- Which means that it
basically hates water.
- Now, we're gonna
basically pour water on it,
and see what happens.
- It looks like it's gonna
be real fun water wise.
- I'm just worried it's gonna bounce off.
- [Woman in overalls]
It's just rejecting it.
- Yeah, yeah, it's like
Superman and bullets.
It just does not give a (beep).
- Yeah.
This is the ultimate clothing material.
Like you'd never get it wet,
you'd never have to iron it.
And also, you'd be invisible.
- So like, if you had this on a car,
like would you never have to wash it?
- Like you could just put it on anything
that you want to not get
wet, like electronics.
- Like, there's not even little droplets.
Oh my god, they should
make Ventablack toilets.
- Oh I didn't expect it
to be so pure looking.
Just completely like, flat,
like no texture at all.
- How much is Ventablack?
I'll buy some.
- We're getting the impression
it's more than we can afford.
- Never mind.
(laughing)
- Actually I'm gonna say
officially that did blow my mind.
- This would be the best
Halloween costume on the planet.
And I'd be invisible, oh my gosh, yes.
This is great, Ventablack tracksuits.
- Yeah.
- Coming to a store near you.
(laughing)